للمره السادسه يقف السياسي المخضرم ورئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي المعين بنيامين
نتنياهو امام الكنيست لتنصيب حكومه
اسرائيل 37 التي توصف بانها الحكومه
الاكثر تشددا في تاريخ الدوله العبريه
في خطاب اداء اليمين امام النواب حددا
نتنياهو اولويات حكومته مصلطه الضوء على
اولويات الشركائه في الائتلاف اليمينيين
المتطرفين والمتدينين دون تغيير كبير في
السياسه الخارجيه
المهمه الاولى
ايران لتطوير البرنامج النووي الذي يهددنا
ويهدد العالم اجمع
سنواصلوا توسيع دائره السلام مع الدول
العربيه بهدف وضع حد نهائي للشراع العربي
الاسرائيلي
مقاطعه خصومه من نواب المعارضه الذين
اتهموه بالضعف من خلال ابرام اتفاقات
وصفوها بالمكلفه السياسيه مع شركاء جدد في
اشاره الى حزبي الصهيونيه الدينيه والقوه
اليهوديه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ينظر الى
تنصيب حكومه اسرائيليه من اليمين المتطرف
تسعى لتوسيع المستوطنات اليهوديه بالضفه
الغربيه بمزيد من التخوف فيما تحذر حركه
حماس من اي تصعيد
الحكومه المقبله تمثل عبث حقيقي
زيزو الاستيطان في مناطق تعتبرها حقا من
حقوق الشعب اليهودي